then we'll expect the super heavy to
light up its 33 Raptor engines at the
base of the vehicle and the liftoff
clear the pad away down from Starbucks
in Starbase Texas and then it'll go into
Ascent about three minutes into its
Ascent we're gonna expect to see super
heavy separate from the Starship it'll
perform a flip maneuver and then it'll
execute a boost back burn and we're
going to be targeting a hard Landing in
the Gulf of Mexico and while that's
happening we hope to see starship's six
second stage engines ignite and watch as
Starship coasts for about an hour at
altitudes ranging between 150 and 250
kilometers before re-entering Earth's
atmosphere and make its own hard Landing
in the Pacific Ocean about 250-ish
kilometers offshore now we are not
really expecting many camera views after
separation that is to say if we even
make it that far but we do promise that
whatever views we do have we will bring
them to you live yeah up uh we have a
couple of ground stations along the way
so if we are able to get good Telemetry
assuming we make it that far into the
ascent and of course those will be
available on the stream
um and also worth mentioning today like
the whole just getting the vehicle off
the pad is a complex Endeavor we are
going to be trying to reduce complexity
by attempting those hard water Landings
instead of trying a normal Landing like
you're used to on Falcon 9. exactly we
are not attempting to recover these
vehicles so yeah hard Landings in store
for both now in a little bit we'll take
a closer look at the vehicle and the
launch pad but first the teams have been
doing a tremendous amount of work over
the last few months in fact there's a
great shot of our farm team up here
bright and early to watch the launch uh
it seems have been prepping really for
the last few days especially to try to
get into today's launch intense
and here you can see a live view of the
South Padre Amphitheater where both
SpaceX employees friends and family and
members of the public are gathering to
watch Starship liftoff uh and we can see
the Crowds Are Gathering there as well
and of course we want to give a shout
out to the SpaceX team you see them
there on screen members of our launch
commands uh excuse me our Star Command
Center that is our star-based launch
control center yep those are the
operators today we're going to be
reviewing all the data and of course
giving us the the go no go poll checking
the status to try to get in today's
launch attempt just around 27 minutes
from now and one thing I do want to
mention I misspoke it's not the South
Padre Amphitheater it's the Cameron
County Amphitheater
now the entire Starship structure on
your screen is made from stainless steel
when it's stacked it stands about 120
meters tall it's about nine meters
around and we have this awesome video
that shows you just how big that is uh
you can see one of our technicians there
doing some final prep work in advance of
today's test and man there's the 120
liter monster the person just keeps
getting smaller and smaller now just
like Falcon 9 Starship has two stages
which we'll talk more about those in a
minute in addition to those two stages
Starship actually has a third stage
which we call stage zero it consists of
all the launch pad infrastructure built
around the rocket as you can see there
on your screen and it's truly an
engineering fee in its own right yeah
we've got a great shot there of the
various different components of it uh
the pad the infrastructure
um the all that is required to get into
filling the the tanks now let's talk
about the super heavy it is the name
says everything it's super it's heavy
it's super heavy when it's operational
it'll be responsible for providing the
power to escape that Mighty
gravitational pull of Earth that we've
got here and take Starship into orbit
the booster itself stands about 70
meters tall and is roughly the same
height as a fully integrated Falcon 9
which is just so crazy to me but this
super heavy booster has a diameter
roughly two and a half times that of
Falcon 9 and with 33 much larger engines
we have a beautiful view here this is
one of my favorite views that we're
going to get today those are our 33
Raptor engines at the base of the super
heavy booster yep and you can see
they're they're in a couple of different
Rings here so we've got the outer ring
of 20 static engines they're going to be
providing a huge amount of thrust today
to lift off the entire stack but then
we've got the 13 gimbaling engines in
the middle and they're going to be
providing the Tilt Maneuvers and also
helping to reorient the booster as it
comes back later in today's flight yeah
and when we say gimbal it's basically
tilting or almost wiggling the engines a
few degrees and in either direction to
allow the booster to steer itself just
as you said to them and we'll get some
shots later of actually a wiggle test
that we we perform ahead of liftoff just
to make sure that all those engines are
able to take control of their full range
of Control Authority uh one thing to
note those Raptor engines that are
completely designed and manufactured
in-house they are as many of you know
that have been following along they are
a reusable methane oxygen staged
combustion type engine so it's a lot of
words there and ultimately that staged
combustion means that we combust the
propellant in stages that we kind of
pre-combust them in a pre-burner and by
doing so it allows the engine to be more
efficient I.E more powerful yeah
now uh like Falcon 9 the super heavy has
four grid fins to assist with orienting
itself in its return back to Earth we
got a shot of him there uh Beneath The
Starships aft flaps now as we talked
about earlier super heavy is not going
to be attempting a land Landing today
but with this flight test we're still
trying to get as much data as we can
we're focusing on the fundamental
systems and operations so that's the
liftoff portion but we are going to try
to get some data on how the fins work
and for that uh water landing that super
heavy is going to be making after a set
I love that great view of the fins there
now Starship or the spacecraft is the
second stage and it makes up the top
portion of the vehicle it's designed for
carrying passengers and cargo to Earth
orbit and Beyond it stands about 50
meters tall which is a little taller
than the Statue of Liberty it's
comprised of six Raptor engines three
sea level and three vacuum engines which
are optimized to operate in the vacuum
of space and they provide a maximum of
258 000 tons of thrust in vacuum
spacecraft is also outfitted with four
flaps to help aerodynamically control
the vehicle's attitude which you can see
those two forward flaps there on your
screen now so they help control the
vehicle's attitude during atmospheric
flight and enable precise landing at the
intended location now one thing we got
to mention the heat shields they are
iconic Starship is wrapped in a heat
shield which is composed of 18 000
hexagonals ceramic tiles designed to
insulate the vehicle during that
atmospheric entry and that's really
important because the temperatures can
be as high as 2 600 degrees Fahrenheit
the heck shaped tiles like the ones that
Shiva and I have roughly make up about
two-thirds of the vehicle we can see
that we have thirds of the vehicle we
can see that we have some different
shapes mine is slightly curved as you
can imagine it sits on the curved
portions of the Starship vehicle now the
one that I've got is a hex signal tile
that's more flat and it's really used
for the flatter structures on the
vehicle and we need a heat shield
because when you're coming back in from
re-entry we're going supersonic we're
compressing all the air ahead of us that
ends up causing a lot of heating along
the surface and without a heat shield
that would go straight into the
structure yeah one thing that's amazing
to me especially when I first picked up
one of these heat shield tiles is that
they're so light they almost feel like
they're made out of foam they're they're
that light and they they kind of sound
like it too and one thing that we do
want to mention in order to reject the
maximum amount of heat during that entry
like Shiva was just saying they're black
and that's because black helps reject
that heat as that is building up on the
exterior of the heat shield
now Starship is designed for vertical
takeoff and Landing as opposed to taking
off and Landing like an airplane and
that's because that that's really
important because we don't have runways
on the moon or Mars fortunately at those
destinations the gravity is not as high
as it is here on Earth on Mars the
gravity is just one third of what it is
here on Earth and on the moon is just a
sixth so in both of those cases Starship
with just its engines can take off
without needing the super heavy booster
like we do need here on planet Earth now
for today's test Starship does not have
its Landing lights attached because like
we said before it won't be returning
anywhere Starship is expected to make a
very hard ocean Landing which if we even
make it that far and manage to get any
views uh it will certainly make for a
very exciting end to today's test at
this point in time we are uh 20 minutes
or just over 20 minutes from liftoff
let's check in with John insprecker for
a status update John how's it looking
thanks Kate I'm John insprecker
principal integration engineer here at
SpaceX we're currently loading
propellant from the ground system into
both the first and second stages
now both vehicles use the same two
propellants that commonality helps build
the reliability
and the feel today is liquid nothing and
that's at a temperature of just over 100
kelvins that's about minus 272 degrees
below zero on the Fahrenheit scale
Now liquid methane is a different fuel
from Falcon 9. that booster uses rp1
kerosene
however our oxidizer is liquid oxygen
and that's the same as falcon 9. because
there is no oxygen in space to support
combustion we have to bring our own
now leading up to where we are right now
we had a go no go pole that was
conducted just after T minus two hours
and once the team gave their goes we
started loading propellants onto the
booster at T minus one hour and 39
minutes
a T minus one hour and 22 minutes we
began propellant loading of the ship the
second stage you can see on your screen
right there
now propellant loading of the starship's
second stage main tanks completed at
about the T-minus 27 minute Mark at
which time we then began loading the two
header tanks in the nose of the second
stage
now T minus three minutes when the first
stage super heavy propellant loading
completes that means we'll have all the
propellant on the rocket and the vehicle
will be fully loaded with over 10
million pounds of propellant
now right now at T minus 19 minutes and
Counting from liftoff the weather and
winds are looking good we have been
watching the ground level winds they're
at 18 miles an hour as the morning
continues they will increase but that is
below our limits right now we're also
looking at upper altitude winds we're
waiting for one more balloon but we
believe that we're going to be go
on the launch vehicle itself the teams
the good news they're not working any
issues right now but if for some reason
we do not make our test flight today if
we have to hold
we have a backup launch window however
we're not sure when it would be it could
be 24 or 48 hours after today it'll
depend on how far we get into the
countdown but right now heading for a
t-0 at 8 28 Central 1328 universal time
okay everything is looking good awesome
news now in order to make life
multi-planetary we need a fully reusable
vehicle that's capable of carrying a
huge amount of cargo and a lot of people
to orbit and have a pretty quick
turnaround the idea is to effectively
reuse launch Vehicles just like
airplanes yeah imagine if you had to
wait for a new airplane to be
constructed every time you wanted to fly
you'd rarely go anywhere and for most of
us it would be completely unaffordable
in order for us to get to Mars and back
with lots of people lots of cargo
multiple times reusability really is a
must
in advance of our first missions to Mars
Starship will execute a number of
missions with both cargo and people
starting with Earth orbit and eventually
expanding to the moon and Beyond now in
the near term and a bit closer to home
Starship will also be critical to other
programs once fully operational it'll
deliver the full-size and upgraded
version of our starlink satellites and
that's super exciting because our next
Generation satellites represent a step
forward in starlink's capabilities and
will allow us to connect millions of
more people around the world with
high-speed internet so watch watch
webcasts such an exciting future ahead
of us but first let's talk a little
about how we got to where we are today
now Starships testing ramped up in July
of 2019 with our star Hopper prototype
sort of a short version of the Starship
that we see today there's a great photo
of it it was just over 18 meters tall it
had a single Raptor engine and we had it
to test fly and perform low-level
altitude Maneuvers and attempt Landing
the initial test light or hop reached
about 20 meters in altitude that was
followed by the one that you've got on
your screen here this was our 150 meter
altitude hop we went up took a little
jaunt away about 100 meters or so away
from the launch pad use that Raptor
engine to fly and actually land and
actually this uh Hopper is actually down
at Starbase now yeah I love this shot
it's just so fun to see it fly after a
series of 150 meter hop tests with
earlier prototypes the Starship program
saw a major breakthrough during a test
flight of the vehicle known as serial
number eight or sn8 you can see it there
on your screen now in December 2020 sn8
demonstrated a first of its kind
controlled aerodynamic descent and
Landing split maneuver two words belly
flop
the sn8 Prototype Rose to an altitude of
12.5 kilometers or 7.8 miles and
conducted a belly flop maneuver which
you see there during its descent while
it didn't stick The Landing the test was
a major milestone in the development of
Starship
in fact we should be able to see that
unfortunately failed Landing boom
it was fun to watch though we're having
to unscheduled disassembly but learned a
lot of data now the testing continued on
to prototype serial number nine it took
a 10 kilometer flight it's about 6.2
miles up in February of 2021 we had a
nominal Ascent we executed the engine
cutoffs once we got to the top of the
altitude window we did that belly flop
maneuver which is so much more fun to
say than controlled descent aerodynamic
maneuver that was all stable but
unfortunately we had a dramatic end on
this flight as well we had a failure on
one of the engines that resulted in
another pretty large Fireball but what
was really cool about both of those
flights was how much we learned just
between serial numbers eight and nine
and how quickly we were able to achieve
our primary objectives in those two
flights in addition to that we've just
we got so much data that demonstrated
control of the vehicle and that subsonic
regime ultimately we performed nine
Starship high altitude test flights in
total and then as you see on your screen
there in May of 2021 sn15 launched from
Starbase reached an altitude of about 10
kilometers performed a number of
Maneuvers and safely returned to the
launch site this was the first Starship
prototype to fly control its descent
safely land and be recovered in one
piece and people were cheering like
crazy
now having achieved those successes in
our suborbital campaign one of the next
big challenges is for the upper stage
when it comes to reusability and
surviving the Hypersonic really high
heating phase of Entry combined with the
later ability to refill starship's tank
with propellants the fuel and oxygen
while we're on orbit that will enable us
to have a fully reusable transportation
system that's designed to carry both
crew and cargo on long duration missions
interplanetary flights and will help
Humanity get to the Moon travel to Mars
and Beyond in our solar system
this is all uh just basically our path
of progress uh basically an iteration on
each vehicle and that iterative process
is a core part of how we work here at
SpaceX we like to test early and often
uh public publicly as well in our case
and that's both for hardware and
software and while it doesn't always go
as expected we learn so much from it and
it informs our next attempt yeah we
learn a lot from actually putting the
vehicle through flight like tests even
the test on Monday gave us an
opportunity to learn more about the
vehicle into today's launch attempt and
so far things are looking really good
now we are continuing into our countdown
we're about T minus 12 minutes to go I
think it's the perfect time for another
check-in with John insparker how's it
going John well sure the good news is
that the Nets are quiet the teams are
currently working no significant launch
vehicle issues you can see the T clock
there on your screen T minus 12 minutes
10 seconds and counting
propeller loading is continuing on both
the super heavy and the shift stages you
can see the graphic on the left hand
side of the screen most recently we
began loading liquid oxygen and liquid
methane fill into the header tanks on
Starship those are two small tanks just
underneath the nose of the second stage
now that started at T minus 27 minutes
that'll be wrapping up at about T minus
t minus F that will be wrapping up about
T minus nine minutes
now the Starship second stage main feel
and locks tanks are loaded for flight
right now
the super heavy first stage booster
propellant loading is continuing and
that'll go till about T minus three
minutes
we're underway with engine chill as we
get ready for t0
and we're also conferring the launch pad
for liftoff the booster hold Downs have
been unlatched they'll be ready to
retract at liftoff and the second stage
quick disconnect is beginning its
configuration for release the methane
and liquid oxygen propellants currently
going to the second stage go through
that quick disconnect that's that arm
that reaches out from the tower to the
base of the second stage
the SpaceX team continues to check in
with the Coast Guard good news is we've
not heard any reports of boats in the
safety perimeter as the launch vehicle
heads out over the Gulf of Mexico so
right now T minus 10 minutes 40 seconds
and counting everything continues to go
well for an on-time launch now today's
test flight is taking place out of our
star base facility in south Texas and
that test site has gone through a huge
amount of development over the last
couple of years
one thing I want to point out this is a
great view from our drone not only can
we see the pad but in the fog kind of in
the distance in the background and to
the left of the pad you can actually see
our production facility uh which is the
other part of Starbase in addition to
the launch pad of course as part of
rapidly iterating with our test program
we're also rapidly iterating on our
production system to produce starships
and super Heavies last year the
star-based team produced four-star ship
super heavy boosters and five Starships
along with their 200th Raptor 2 engine
and they're only scaling up from their
case yeah it's incredible to think that
for 2023 production has five boosters
and eight Starships going so it's
incredible and it's important to have
that system fill in basically the
manufacturing line so that we have
product ready to go as soon as we're
done uh with this test yeah exactly and
ultimately I mean we talked about how
Stars is an order of magnitude more
propellant excuse me payload so orbit
but if you're gonna go set up a base on
the moon or Mars you're gonna need
thousands of metric tons of propellants
and so you're going to need a fleet of
vehicles that's capable of doing that
yeah one thing to note Starbase directly
employs more than 1800 employees uh it's
the largest employer in the area in fact
um and we're very thankful to Cameron
County for being so supportive uh This
Is A View From the uh Cameron County
Amphitheater
um and it there's a crowd there and I
could you could tell by the energy here
in Hawthorne as well that everyone's
getting really exciting I feel my own
heart rate going up and up I know it
must be really really exciting to go see
this and I mean just the sheer amount of
power on Starship you're gonna feel it
down there uh when this thing lifts off
from the pad we've actually got a great
shot here of of the natural surroundings
around the pad oddly enough most of the
pads end up being around sort of uh wild
locations like this
um wild locations like this but coming
up on T-minus eight minutes I think it's
another good time for check-in with John
hi Kashima T-minus
just over eight minutes to the first
test flight of Starship
currently we are pressurizing second
stage we are also closing out liquid
oxygen and fuel header loads on the
second stage we're also getting ready
for propellants
pressurization on the first stage
in fact uh we are just now closing out
header tank load on the second stage
now with the header tanks loaded and
closed out that means we're down to just
the first stage
to finish loading that'll finish about T
minus three minutes
and at that point when both stages are
loaded we will have the 10 million
pounds of liquid propellant on board
now in the next few minutes the guidance
system will begin its final alignment
for flight during a quiet period when
the Rocket's not doing anything
the automated flight termination system
will be armed and a final TVC checkout
will be performed those are the engine
Wiggles and hopefully we'll be able to
see that with the cameras underneath the
vehicle and maybe even the second stage
engines there's a view looking
underneath
the super heavy first stage with the 33
Raptor engines
now a reminder as we continue counting
down if we do need to hold the point
where we hold the clock would be a T
minus 40 seconds we can pause there
typically in the past if we need a
little bit more time to finish final
checkouts or do some pressurization of
the onboard storage tanks that's where
we would hold
but currently we're not hearing a need
to hold so it's six minutes 27 seconds
everything looks good and of course Kate
Shiva as we get close we're going to get
into the engine ignition sequence of 33
Rafters and that's going to be something
new for everybody I cannot wait to that
moment so for those of you that are
familiar with how we launch Falcon 9
Rockets you probably know that we light
all nine of those first stage Merlin 1D
engines all at once it's pretty
different than what we do or what we're
attempting to do today we're actually
going to be igniting those 33 engines in
Banks or clusters and that sequence
starts at T minus six seconds yeah and
the ignition sequence is a little bit
different uh both in terms of the timing
and also the ignition method so on
Falcon 9 we use the chemical called
t-tab it's a pyrophoric materials that
means when you mix the two together it
produces a flame that kicks off that
green characteristic spark on Falcon 9
missions but actually on Starship we use
electrical ignition systems many of
those are integrated on the ground
system here and the electrical ignition
we start lighting the banks at T minus
six seconds and then over the next four
seconds the three sets of banks will
ignite and eventually bring uh the
booster up to a Thrust to weight greater
than one and hopefully Ascend super
exciting like we said pretty different
from our Falcon 9 launches and so this
will be the first time that any of us
have gotten to see this type of an of uh
integrated test flight with both the
Starship and the super heavy booster
everyone's hearing as we get
[Applause]
in minutes
we want to remind everyone that success
today is anything
yeah it looks fun down there
for today success is anything that we
learned that helps improve the future
build of Starship if we lift off and
clear the pad we're calling that a win
a great shot of the pad there a great
shot of the quick disconnect on the
second stage you can see the frost line
on the booster where that methane is uh
is fully topped up I think we're just
coming up on the last few minutes here
of propellant sale on the booster
and that quick disconnect is going to
separate away as we actually get into
the ignition sequence but it's providing
electrical connections now and uh also
providing the propellants that we're
loading into the the vehicle yeah
we're just now under four minutes until
liftoff of these Starship flight test
we've been following along for it what
honestly seems like days and days now
but really it kind of comes down to
years it has been a long time to get to
where we are today now fast forwarding a
little bit we have the opportunity to
hold if necessary at 40 seconds and we
are able to hold there for about 15
minutes or up to 15 minutes and still be
able to lift off yeah and that's a
little bit different from Falcon uh for
the propellant sequence on Falcon that
um we don't have the opportunity to hold
so that's a cool new capability on
Starship
right now T minus three minutes 10
seconds and counting we've got some
great views from the Drone
it's nice that the fog is slowly lifting
we get some of the blue skies hopefully
good views
what we're waiting for right now is
close out of propellant loading on the
first stage
that should be wrapping up here shortly
in fact it looks like uh fuel fill and
drain valves are coming closed that
means first stage is fully loaded second
stage fully loaded and at 10 million
pounds per pellet on board the Starship
launch vehicle
I want to take a quick moment to say
that the cloud energy here is electric I
feel like it's Falcon heavy test demo
all over again
foreign
and hopefully you'll hear us as we get
into the plus count but right now next
activity is coming up the flight
termination system arms at T minus two
minutes thrust vector control checkouts
at T minus two minutes and then after
that major activity will be the T-minus
42nd gate
there's the view looking up at the 33
Raptor engines
there are 20 engines and a circle on the
outside and as Shiva said earlier 13
engines on the center those are the ones
that demo
foreign
love this view these are the 33 Raptor
engines at the base of the super heavy
booster
I think we can see those Wiggles now
we're currently inside 90 seconds
next major activity T-minus 40 seconds
that is a gate or decision point we're
waiting possibility the propulsion team
may need a few minutes
flight termination system is armed for
flight we're getting ready for T minus
one minute and Counting
[Applause]
next we'll see as we get past T minus 40
seconds for final checks of the vehicle
[Applause]
foreign
okay you can see the clock
is recycled
flight director has called a hold we are
recycling
for the moment we'll see where they move
the clock back to they could hold at T
minus 40 seconds they could go to an
earlier point
give us a minute to listen into the Nets
and we'll see if we can get you more
information to share
found inspector again here at the
Hawthorne webcast desk we're holding a
T-minus 40 seconds what we've heard so
far is we have a couple of issues we're
working one is the booster tank
pressurization uh final pressurization
was just a little bit long that's not
unusual we've held at T minus 40 seconds
before to pressurize that appears to
have been resolved at the same time on
the second stage they're working some
final purging we should know very
shortly if that is cleared and if we'll
continue the countdown
everyone especially that person is
excited to keep going like John said we
should know shortly if we are able to
continue but as we mentioned before we
are able to hold uh up to 15 minutes and
still be able to lift off today yeah on
Falcon 9 it's a little bit different
once we start propellant loading we
pretty much have to go at the targeted
time otherwise the propellants can warm
up and we may not have the performance
for that particular Mission profile it's
a little bit different
if I can interrupt yeah it looks like
they're clearing all the flags and we're
going to release at T minus 40 seconds
that is amazing news amazing
team working quickly through their
issues on first and second stages
and I'm sure all of the rehearsals and
simulations that they've been doing have
prepared them to evaluate this data
quickly
to try to get us in for today's launch
attempts
joining we have a brief hold at the
T-minus 42nd Mark the team is resolving
one issue with the police merge on the
stage two Raptors like John just said
the teams are quickly working that and
it looks like the flags are being
cleared as we speak so we should be able
to resume the launch countdown any
moment now
and it's worth noting on Starship that
once we resume the countdown it restarts
from the 42nd period and then we keep
going unless another condition pops up
so stick around because uh Starship
could be going here real soon
don't walk away that's for sure
amazing views here coming to us from
Starbase Texas
okay
[Applause]
purpose
hurry up
[Applause]
foreign
back up
going through the period of Maximum
aerodynamic pressure
as the velocity increases the depth of
the atmosphere is decreasing lessening
stress on the vehicle to call out next
to you now
foreign
to watch the first stage as we head down
range
100 seconds into flight
our next major activity
over the first stage
Houston tracking station now acquiring
the vehicle
[Applause]
separates we light up six engines in the
staggered sequence and if all goes well
those six engines will burn for almost
six and a half minutes I bar view from
Star
s and their views of the Raptor engines
on the second stage as we prepare for
stage separation now after safe
separation the first stage will flip and
begin a boost back maneuver for landing
in the Gulf
[Music]
continuing to fly two minutes 40 seconds
let's get ready for main engine cut off
beginning the flip for stage separation
okay
[Music]
as of right now we are awaiting stage
separation
where Starship should separate from the
super heavy booster
yeah Kate right now it looks like we saw
the start of the flip but obviously
we're seeing from the ground cameras the
entire Starship stack continuing to
rotate we should have had Separation by
now obviously this is uh does not appear
to be a nominal situation yeah it does
appear to be spinning but I do want to
remind everyone that everything after
clearing the tower was icing on the cake
foreign
[Applause]
tegrated light of the booster and the
Starship vehicle
live view bear of our control center at
Starbase which we refer to as Star
Command
as we said before obviously we wanted to
make it all the way through but to get
this far honestly is amazing
well if you're just joining us Starship
Just experience what we call a rapid
unscheduled disassembly or a rut during
Ascent but now this was a development
test there's a first test fly to
Starship and the goal is to gather the
data and as we said clear the pad and
get ready to go again so you never know
exactly what's going to happen but as we
promised excitement is guaranteed and
Starship gave us a rather spectacular
and what was truly an incredible test
thus far
as we mentioned at the start of today's
program any and all the data that we
collected during the test is going to
help us with further development of
Starship and it's going to improve the
vehicle's reliability as SpaceX seeks to
make life multi-planetary it's really
worth noting that the flight path was
designed to be over water and all the
air and sea space along with that flight
path and those surrounding areas we
cleared in advance of the test and of
course we're going to be coordinating
with local authorities for the recovery
operations but honestly
from Starbase Texas at 8 28 a.m central
time we cleared the tower which honestly
was our only hope we cleared the tower
and all the data that we collected all
the way through the all those Raptors
those 33 although I think we saw that
three Raptor engines were out but we got
all that data and we got so far as to
hoping to see the the Starship the
second stage separates from the first
stage the super heavy booster and
unfortunately we didn't make that happen
but that's okay it was the first
integrated launch and honestly today was
amazing
absolutely incredible day we made it
through a number of those initial test
objectives with getting booster Ascent
getting all the way through the
countdown working some issues at the end
like really fantastic day got through
the gate of T minus 40 seconds on the
second try everything released the hold
Downs quick disconnect arms everything
moves out of the way and then we got the
vehicle off of the pad through Max Q all
the way up to Stage separation even
starting into the prep for States up and
then as we say a lot of excitement yeah
honestly my face has had a smile on it
so it's left off and now my face hurts
no since we don't have any insights on
the cause of our rapid unscheduled
disassembly at this point we're going to
end our webcast here teams will continue
to review the data and work toward our
next flight test but before we go a big
congrats to the entire SpaceX team on an
exciting first integrated flight test of
Starship and of course a shout out to
our viewers we appreciate you joining us
and as always we thank you for your
interest in Starship SpaceX and your
ongoing support
till next time
[Music]
thank you